a few hours from now president Trump
will board Air Force One and fly to
Vietnam to meet for the second time with
North Korean leader Kim jong-un Kim is
expected to arrive in Vietnam this
morning after a two-day trip by train
and car now the talks will focus again
on Kim's nuclear arsenal but the
president and his Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo seemed to be sending mixed
signals on how big a threat North Korea
really is then Tracie is in Hanoi
Vietnam is capital where the summit will
begin in just about 36 hours then good
morning good morning after that first
summit in Singapore the Trump
administration said that an expected
North Korea to start taking immediate
steps to get rid of its nuclear weapons
well that has not happened and now just
days before the second summit here in
Hanoi President Trump seems to be trying
to manage expectations we have a special
feeling and I think it's gonna lead to
something very good and maybe not
speaking to the US governor's Sunday
night president Trump said he's no
longer pushing North Korea to quickly
give up its nuclear weapons I'm not in a
rush I don't want to rush anybody I just
don't want testing as long as there's no
testing we're happy North Korea has not
tested a missile or nuclear device for
more than 400 days a self-imposed pause
long before the Singapore summit Kim
jong-un claims he's already completed
his nuclear program and no longer needs
the tests but there is ample evidence
that the regime is still producing
nuclear fuel working on its weapons
programs and evading international
sanctions North Korea has taken no clear
steps towards denuclearization despite
president Trump's tweet after the
Singapore summit that there's no longer
a nuclear threat from North Korea
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
contradicted that claim do you think
North Korea remains a nuclear threat yes
but the president said he doesn't it's
not what he said what he said is that
that what he said was that the efforts
that had been made in Singapore this
commitment that chairman Kim made have
substantially taken down the risk to the
American people
secretary Pompeo says this process may
take time that it may require more
summits you may recall after that first
summit there was this vaguely worded
document that said that they would work
towards the complete denuclearization of
the Korean Peninsula
well now Trump administration officials
acknowledged that part of this summit
will be to define what that term
actually means John indeed Ben Tracy and
Vietnam thanks Ben